I do have this idea of making some sort
of house edit of Joe Rogan like taking a
podcast clip and turning it into a house
song but playing it off like oh [__] I
press play on the wrong things my
podcast folder and then it like turns
into a house song careful man the Joe
Bros don't play they'll be like oh well
I thought we were actually gonna play an
episode yeah they're gonna hear it and
they're gonna stop dancing and go oh
this is [__] episode 1073. yeah yeah
yo let this run this is a good one and
then they're just gonna start chatting
and pontificating sharing ideas yeah I
like this creatine because this one
makes me diarrhea less yeah especially
during March Madness weekend that'll
probably [__] work yeah